Set three years after Return of the Jedi,
the Disney+ Star Wars series The Mandalorian
follows a lone gunslinger who works outside
of the law.
The cast features actors from the world of
Game of Thrones, the X-Men universe, and even
the Rocky movies.
Here's how you might know them.
From the moment that Pedro Pascal's Prince
Oberyn Martel strutted into King's Landing,
Game of Thrones gained a new fan-favorite
character.
"You shouldn't drink before a fight."
"You learn this during your years in the fighting
pits?
I always drink before a fight."
As the "Red Viper," Pascal was able to leave
an extremely memorable mark on the series,
especially with his grisly death.
Pascal has also had a slew of minor roles
in television, including playing Nathan Landry
in The Good Wife.
He also played Javier Peña in the Netflix
original series Narcos.
As for noteworthy movies, Pascal appeared
in the action flick Kingsman: The Golden Circle
and the drama If Beale Street Could Talk.
At 2019's Star Wars Celebration in Chicago,
Pascal briefly touched on his upcoming role
in The Mandalorian, in which he plays the
protagonist, saying,
"The Mandalorian is a mysterious lone gunman
in the outer reaches of the galaxy.
Some might say that he has questionable moral
character, which is in line with some of our
best Westerns, some good samurai [films]...and
he's a badass."
In this day and age, it's not uncommon for
famous MMA fighters to make the transition
to acting.
Add Gina Carano to the list.
Carano's first leading role came in 2011,
when she played Mallory Kane in the adrenaline-pumping
action movie Haywire.
Since then, she has played minor parts in
a couple of blockbuster smashes, including
2013's Fast & Furious 6 and 2016's Deadpool.
In The Mandalorian, Carano will be playing
Cara Dune, an ex-rebel shock trooper who is
apparently having some trouble reintegrating
into society after the last big star war.
Although not much is known of her character,
Carano took to her Instagram and shared the
first image of her character, commenting about
her time at Star Wars Celebration.
She wrote,
"I can't describe the energy I felt...It was
incredible and I'm so grateful for all of
you and the crazy awesome support you showed
us.
I'm so stoked...that was epic."
Carl Weathers is a Hollywood icon, with a
well-rounded acting resume of notable roles,
including Apollo Creed in the Rocky franchise
and Dillon in Predator.
In the '90s, he embodied the hilarious golf-legend-turned-coach
Chubbs Peterson in Adam Sandler's timeless
comedy, Happy Gilmore.
In The Mandalorian, Weathers will be playing
the role of Greef Carga.
Although the details of his character are
still under wraps, the actor took the podium
at this year's Star Wars Celebration in Chicago
to offer some insight into his role, saying,
"He's kind of the head of this guild of bounty
hunters.
There seems to be a lot of kind of nefarious
people.
He's looking for someone to go after a product
for a client that's very valuable."
A native of Copenhagen, Denmark, Giancarlo
Esposito has played major parts in huge television
series and lent his trademark, silky-smooth
voice and charisma to several successful motion
pictures.
He is perhaps most recognized for his role
as Gustavo Fring, the drug-kingpin employer
of Walter White in AMC's Breaking Bad.
Like most facets of The Mandalorian, Esposito's
role is still largely unknown.
However, in an interview with Collider, the
Emmy-nominated actor briefly opened up about
his time on set, saying,
"I've got a great costume.
We got great set pieces.
I'm not giving anything away because [Jon
Favreau] is an artist, truly an artist.
[He was] working with George Lucas on this
particular piece and making it a piece that
we can really relate to now in our world that
we're in."
Can you imagine anyone but Harrison Ford playing
the iconic role of Han Solo in 1977's A New
Hope?
Several higher-profile actors were considered
for the part before Ford - at the time a relative
unknown - landed it.
One of those actors was Nick Nolte, the star
of 1977's The Deep.
In an interview with MTV, Nolte admitted that
he felt he would have been, quote, "kind of
a goofy Star Wars guy."
Now, as it turns out, he will get to be a
goofy Star Wars guy in The Mandalorian, though
the nature of his role is still unclear.
Nolte has built up quite a respectable acting
resume over the years, as proven by his three
Oscar nominations.
He is perhaps most recognized for his role
as Jack Cates in 1982's 48 Hrs. and its 1990
sequel, Another 48 Hrs.
"You're done.
End of story."
Although he is now well into the back nine
of his career, Nolte is hardly slowing down,
appearing over the past decade in projects
like 2015's A Walk in the Woods, and 2018's
The Padre.
Fans of the CW's Supernatural will no doubt
recognize Emily Swallow, who played the seductive,
archangel-slaying Amara, a.k.a. the Darkness.
The 39-year-old actress has also held a number
of minor roles in various television shows,
including The Mentalist and How to Get Away
with Murder.
Her big screen debut came in 2008's The Lucky
Ones, briefly sharing the screen with Rachel
McAdams and Tim Robbins.
Although details about her character in The
Mandalorian remain shrouded in mystery, Swallow's
twitter feed suggests that she had a great
time on set, particularly while working with
a special co-star.
She wrote,
"Working with @TaikaWaititi on one of my episodes
of #TheMandalorian fulfilled a very weird
and off-kilter dream of mine."
After directing the wildly successful Thor:
Ragnarok, Taika Waititi became a household
name for fans of comic book movies.
In addition to lending his voice to the hilariously
dry Kronan warrior, Korg, Waititi also made
a splash in the acting world with his role
in the 2014 vampire comedy, What We Do in
the Shadows, which he also co-directed and
produced.
As it turns out, Waititi, who will also be
directing an episode of the series, will be
voicing the droid IG-11 in The Mandalorian.
Star Wars fans will recognize this droid as
being a similar build to IG-88, an assassin
droid who was among the group of bounty hunters
hired by Darth Vader to hunt down Han Solo
and the Millennium Falcon in The Empire Strikes
Back.
German filmmaker Werner Herzog is perhaps
best known for his directorial work overseas,
including existential dramas about the human
will like 1982's Fitzcarraldo.
However, he has also tried his hand at acting
more than a few times, like when he appeared
alongside Tom Cruise in Jack Reacher.
Eagle-eyed fans of NBC's Parks & Recreation
might also recognize him from his cameo as
spooky homeowner Keg Jeggings in an episode
from the show's seventh season.
"So this place has had zero offers?"
"People seem to be scared off, on account
of it being haunted."
When speaking to the Associated Press, Herzog,
who will be playing a villain in The Mandalorian,
applauded the series as a return to classic
filmmaking compared to other slick blockbuster
projects, saying,
"The Mandalorian was filmed not like all the
other Star Wars or other big event films [with]
green screen, green screen everywhere...You
see the landscape, you see the formation.
The camera could even be handheld and move
in between us, seeing the same landscape.
It's not green screen and artificiality.
It brings movie making back to where it should
be.
It's a phenomenal, phenomenal achievement."
Although Omid Abtahi was excited about landing
a role in The Mandalorian, according to Discussing
Film, he wasn't always a Star Wars fanatic.
He told the outlet,
"I hadn't seen any of the Star Wars films
other than The Last Jedi...But when I got
offered the role, I realized I had to go and
watch them...and fell madly in love with [them]
and I am now beating myself for waiting so
long to watch it."
While it is rumored the newly-minted Star
Wars fan will be playing an ex-Imperial Intelligence
officer named Dr. Pershing, not much else
is known of Abtahi's role.
The American-Iranian actor has appeared in
quite a few movies and TV shows throughout
the 2000s.
While he is perhaps best known for his role
in the Starz series American Gods, he has
also appeared in films like 2012's Oscar-winning
Argo, and 2015's The Hunger Games: Mockingjay
- Part 2.
You might also recognize him from his small
roles in various episodes of popular television
series, including Better Call Saul.
In The Mandalorian, Bernard Bullen will be
playing the mysterious role of "Father."
Although this is almost definitely his most
high-profile gig to date, the Spanish/British
actor is no stranger to the screen.
He has appeared in several television shows,
both foreign and domestic, and even has a
few movie roles under his belt.
He briefly appeared on TNT's The Last Ship,
and also played an actor playing Christopher
Columbus in the CW's Jane the Virgin.
It is unclear how significant of a role he
will be playing in The Mandalorian, but Bullen
may well be poised for a major breakout moment.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Star Wars
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.